[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans parlement
hebdo l'émission qui revient sur les
temps forts de l'actualité à l'assemblée
nationale et au sénat
et cette semaine avec brigitte notre
invité la députée annie genevard bonjour
bonjour et c'est brigitte qui vous
présente
bonjour annie genevard bonjour vous êtes
député les républicains du doubs vice
présidente de l'assemblée nationale vous
avez été maire de morteau pendant 15 ans
proche de nicolas sarkozy vous avez
rejoint françois fillon pour la
présidentielle de 2017 et après l'échec
de la droite vous refusez de mettre en
place une opposition constructive à
emmanuel macron résolument dans
l'opposition faites-vous donc partie de
cette nation de 66 millions de
procureurs dénoncé par le président
alors une opposition wii qui joue son
rôle c'est bien le moins qu'on puisse
attendre d'un fonctionnement normalement
démocratique de notre pays
opposition constructive on n'a jamais
fait acte d'opposition sans proposition
donc je tiens à le dire pour nous c'est
très important
sur les 66 millions de procureurs moi je
suis frappé de l'art avec lequel le
président paul eu sa propre
communication au moment où il annonce le
plan en faveur des jeunes des étudiants
c'est maladroit de sa part d'avoir une
table on n'a parlé que de cela alors
même que l'accent aurait dû être mis sur
la détresse des jeunes qui réel et puis
les façons d'y répondre
et puis ça ça évoque une image qui est
un peu désagréable d'un président de la
république d'un côté qui aurait la
vérité qui aurait la légitimité qui
connaîtrait la difficulté de la tâche
et puis 66 millions de français parce
que de qui parle-t-on et des français et
de tous les français qui n'y
comprendraient rien mais ça ne fait du
national défiance aujourd'hui et qui se
mure r
en procureur c'est à dire finalement le
président de la république
il induit l'image de seul contre tous ça
veut dire quoi qu'il n'accepte pas la
démocratie
alors moi je pense qu'il ya une réelle
difficulté de cette majorité a accepté
la critique et on l'a vu encore
récemment avec olivier ferrand au moment
du débat sur l'état d'urgence sanitaire
mais la vue et plein de fois olivier
ferrand qui dit aux parlementaires
sortie d'ici les l'état d'urgence le
recours aux ordonnances les collectifs
de citoyens qui se substituent aux aux
instances délibératives tout ça crée je
crois à une très grande confusion et il
y à des institutions il doit fonctionner
normalement
ce qui n'exclut pas la consultation des
citoyens naturellement dans une
démocratie qui est plus participative
qu'il ne l'a été
allez on va enchaîner sur les titres
l'assemblée commence l'examen du projet
de loi sur les séparatismes ce texte qui
vise à lutter contre l'islamisme radical
crise jusque dans la majorité
feu vert des députés à la prolongation
de l'état d'urgence sanitaire jusqu'au
1er juin dans un climat tendu le
gouvernement ça gaze des critiques de
l'opposition et le sénat a adopté jeudi
une proposition de loi qui crée un
nouveau crime sexuel pour protéger les
mineurs de moins de 13 ans un texte
enrichi de mesures contre l'inceste et
on commence avec l'examen du projet de
loi sur les séparatismes à l'assemblée
[Musique]
l'examen du projet de loi comportant le
respect des principes de la république a
commencé cette semaine en commission à
l'assemblée nationale
il vise à construire l'islam de france
et à lutter contre l'islamisme radical
un sujet clivant même au sein de la
majorité mais c'est un détail de
procédure qui a provoqué la bataille
politique les explications d'elsa
mondain gava près de 300 amendements sur
1800 frappé d'irrecevabilité
inacceptable pour la droite pour nous
ceci est totalement inadmissible c'est
un déni de démocratie
même constat chez les insoumis 30% de
leurs amendements été retoqué le
principe d'un parlement c'est de parler
et le sujet de la discussion
c'est les contradictions ou les accords
qu'il peut y avoir donc ils ont décidé
de faire le ménage entre leurs dépôts et
leur examen en commission les
amendements sont passés au filtre de
l'article 45 de la constitution
il stipule que tout amendement est
recevable en première lecture dès lors
qu'il présente un lien même indirect
avec le texte déposé le président de la
commission spéciale françois de rugy
assume
cela représente donc environ 15% des
amendements du volume global
d'amendements qui a été déclarée
irrecevable
ce qui n'a rien d'exceptionnel article
45 il a été fait tout simplement pour
que sur chaque projet de loi on ne
refasse pas tout la loi dans tous les
domaines mais pour les oppositions
l'application de l'article 45 a été très
stricte voire même politique pour tuer
les débats internes à la majorité
ce gouvernement ne veut pas du débat il
a peur du débat sur le séparatisme il
recule parce qu'il sait qu'il est
divisée et que ce en un temps se
transforme en fête en renoncements
permanent c'est ça la réalité c'est ça
que nous contestons et le parlement il
peut pas être l'otage de chicaya au sein
de la majorité je préfère quand les
oppositions travail et nous présente des
sujets qui sont en lien avec les textes
débattent avec nous on peut être en
désaccord sur de nombreux sujets par de
l'amendement mais il faut pas venir
fabriquer des faux scandale qui sont en
réalité la simple application notre
constitution la droite prend en exemple
amendement d'horreur berger pour
interdire le voile des jeunes filles
mineures
il a créé des héros
dans la majorité mais ne sera finalement
pas discuter annie genevard est-ce que
vous accusez la majorité de détourner
abusivement l'article 45 de la
constitution à des fins politiques
ah oui clairement la censure de beaucoup
de nos amendements est une censure
politique mais c'est tout le problème de
ce texte de loi
en fait le président de la république
aux mureaux annonce qu'il est nécessaire
de prendre des dispositions légales de
modifier le droit pour lutter contre le
séparatisme islamique il nomme
clairement les choses
il dit les choses donc on attendait un
texte puissant qui traite vraiment de ce
problème en réalité on a un texte qui
est loin d attendu qu'on pouvait espérer
escape a quand même un petit problème de
procédure
15% des amendements ont été adoptés
c'est la moyenne normale d'un projet de
loi c'est ce que dit françois de rugy
dans le reportage qu'on vient de voir
et puis la jurisprudence dit qu'il faut
que cet amendement soit rattachée à un
article or il n'y avait pas d'article
par exemple sur le voile pour les
petites filles alors s'il y avait dans
la première partie l'article à à 5
la question de la neutralité religieuse
donc il y avait un lien
la constitution dit même indirect donc
la question de la neutralité religieuse
permet de parler du voile d'ailleurs on
a parlé du voilier des amendements
contre le voile je comprends pas la
lecture que je fais du rejet de
l'amendement berger
moreau je crois c'est le fait qu' il ne
voulait pas qu apparaissent au grand
jour la division de la majorité
c'est ça et elle est apparue plus qui
est malien c'est bien une censure
politique l'amendement berger en est la
parfaite illustration plus de la
majorité que de l'opposition mais bien
sûr est d'ailleurs le les premières
heures du débat en commission ont été
marqués par une très grande agressivité
du ministre de l'intérieur sur cette
question du voile
il a été extrêmement agressif il l'a été
à notre égard mais il l'a été aussi pour
dire à la majorité
attention n'allez pas sur ce terrain là
c'est un terrain qui va occuper le débat
or quelle est la manifestation la plus
évidente de la progression de l'islam
fondamentale radical politique vous le
posez la question aux français les
français sont pleins de bon sens ils
disent c'est le voile vous pouvez
toujours re déposé ces amendements en
séance vous allez le faire
ah oui on va redéposer ces amendements
pour la séance on verra le sort que lui
réserve le président de l'assemblée
nationale parce qu'en séance c'est le
président de l'assemblée nationale qui
juge la recevabilité
il est clair que après je dirais le la
protestation politique qui a résulté de
ce premier set première vague de censure
d'amendements je pense que le président
de l'assemblée nationale sera attentif
de toute façon la procédure qui est
retenue vous l'appelez à cela pour que
le débat puisse se tenir jeudi dans ce
que vous savez on ne gagne jamais rien
museler le débat le débat il se fait
s'il se fait pas l'assemblée nationale
où il doit se faire c'est le sens de nos
institutions
il se fera ailleurs et c'est pas mieux
franchement c'est pas mieux
les républicains ont déjà dans le temps
légiférer sur le voile que ce soit les
signes religieux à l'école ou
l'interdiction de la burqa est ce que si
vous revenez aux responsabilités vous
souhaitez que la droite re les gifs air
sur le voile soit dans l'espace public
soit l'université
moi je pense qu'on n'échappera pas à des
mesures puissante pour dire à ceux qui
veulent subvertir les principes
républicains
nous ferons barrage nous vous ferons
barrage et c'est pas les mesurettes que
contiennent les dispositions de ce texte
qui constitue pour les islamistes je dis
pas pour les musulmans jeudi pour les
cela mist un signal puissant le signal
puissant n'y est pas on a les mots du
président de la république qui parle à
la droite mais on à la réalité d'un
milliard rien de bon y'a rien à garges
ai dit cela
non non non je ne dis pas qu'il n'ya
rien de bon je dis que c'est pas
suffisant pour remplir l'objectif que le
président de la république s'est fixé et
que les français attendent parce que on
a aujourd'hui des territoires qui sont
véritablement séparer de la république
et si on ici on n'y met pas un frein
puissant et bien on va se laisser
déborder
toutes les auditions que nous avons
faites préalablement à ce texte atteste
du fait qu'il est déjà bien tard mon
bien tard quelle est votre position sur
la question de l'instruction à domicile
est-ce que c'est compliqué pour vous de
la critiquer alors qu'elle est
plébiscité aussi par un certain nombre
de familles catholiques aujourd'hui
c'est tout le problème de ce texte pour
pouvoir toucher la cible qu'on veut
atteindre
là en l'occurrence l'enseignement
coranique en lieu et place de l'école
le gouvernement a choisi de pénaliser
l'ensemble des familles qui recourent à
l'instruction en famille beaucoup
d'entre eux sont venus voir les
parlementaires de toute de tous bords
d'ailleurs et on dit mais voilà nous ce
que nous faisons pour instruire nos
enfants et c'est un choix que nous avons
fait à choix du jury et respectable que
il ya un suivi parce que suffisamment de
contrôles danser alors la solution les
dérives sectaires des des dérives aussi
et bien les islamistes bien sûr la
semaine ne vient pas des écoles hors
contrats plus tôt non le problème ne
vient pas des écoles hors contrat ya la
question des écoles hors contrat et la
question aussi de l'enseignement en
famille moi je pense que il faut
contrôler aujourd'hui à trois familles
sur dix qui sont pas contrôlés parce que
les parents échappe au contrôle ils sont
pas là quand on vient il met en avant
des associations donc ils font tout pour
échapper aux contrôles
il faut donc mieux contrôler mais en
fait le gouvernement dans cette affaire
a commencé de reculer d'une part parce
que le conseil d'état lui a dit c'est
pas possible de pénaliser de contraintes
toutes les familles des familles dans la
rue aussi et deuxièmement il ya la
propre majorité qui est divisé sur cette
question là aussi donc c'est cette
affaire est mal emmanchée
et je pense que le ministre va être
obligée d'assouplir mais à une condition
parce que il faut pas que le contrôle
passe de passe par pertes et profits
il faut vraiment mettre fin aux dérives
d'un enseignement hills la musique ça
c'est une absolue priorité
allez on continue cette émission avec la
prorogation de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire à l'assemblée
[Musique]
le texte vise à proroger l'état
d'urgence sanitaire jusqu'au 1er juin il
a été adopté par l'assemblée nationale
malgré les réticences des oppositions
des critiques n'a pas manqué de relever
le ministre de la santé présents dans
l'hémicycle
on écoute je ne voudrais pas qu'on se
quitte parce qu'il nous reste encore du
temps de débat
après des heures de débat et des heures
de présence pour chacun d'entre vous et
moi même dans cet hémicycle sans avoir
abordé aucun sujet de fond moi j'ai
aucun problème avec l'exercice de tir
aux pigeons
je prends quelques formules lancé à
l'emporte-pièce par des députés
d'opposition de droite et de gauche
depuis seulement 15 minutes
nous manquons d'humanité nous manquons
d'humanité nous avons une volonté
totalitaire nous sommes incompétents
nous cumulons les fiascos nous cumulons
les scandales et le parlement est à
l'arrêt madame et messieurs les députés
ça commence à se voir
parler de la part des français cette
espèce d'outrance permanente cette
méthode anti coup et qui voudrait qu'à
chaque fois que la france mettrait en
place quelque chose
immédiatement il y aurait les
parlementaires ou des élus locaux
d'opposition tu as devrait dire que ça
ne marcherait jamais ça commence à se
voir et j'attire votre attention mais je
le dis je le dis en toute sympathie en
toute amitié
je crois que ça commence un peu à lasser
les français annie genevard les
oppositions beaucoup critiqué la
prolongation de cet état d'urgence
est-ce que vous ne perdez pas en
crédibilité à force de vous opposer
non alors dans cette affaire ce que nous
demandons nous c'est que l'état
d'urgence sanitaire ne soit pas aussi
long là nous allons jusqu en juin donc
on a encore six mois d'état d'urgence
sanitaire
nous nous voulons que le parlement soit
régulièrement consultés sur ces sujets
au fond ce que nous disons au
gouvernement c'est vous ne pouvez pas
faire sans les représentants du peuple
que sont les députés
vous ne pouvez pas faire sans l'avis du
parlement régulièrement et c'est
tellement génial cours et on n'en voit
pas la mêlée la d'urgence ne protège pas
finalement mais il a gagné les français
tout se gère entre le conseil de défense
le gouvernement
le conseiller scientifique il faut aussi
la démocratie il impose que les français
soient représentés par leurs élus c'est
ça que me disent on désigne à caen pour
vous on peut prolonger à gérard larcher
dit lui qui demande au sénat qu'il
faille seulement prolonger jusque fin
avril avant d'avoir à nouveau jouer via
un vote du parlement vous êtes d'accord
là dessus je pense que c'est un bon
terme avril mais je pense qu'il faut
vraiment que on évite d'instruire va
d'instaurer des états d'urgence parce
que avec l'état d'urgence et le
confinement possible c'est le couvre-feu
c'est les limitations dans la liberté de
déplacement c'est si vous voulez c'est
quand même une contrainte sur nos
libertés individuelles et collectives
extrêmement forte ceux troisième
confinement vous le voyez se profiler à
l'horizon
écouter vraiment j'espère de tout coeur
qu'on n'arrivera pas là qu'on en
arrivera pas là parce que ce serait
terrible je serai terrible d'abord pour
les français qui sont très éprouvés
on le voit avec la détresse des jeunes
ce serait terrible aussi pour notre
économie et ce à un dur a forcément des
problèmes de santé chez les salariés et
les vendredis opposerait à ce troisième
comme moi je dis tous tout faire pour
éviter le confinement si véritablement
il fallait que l'alliance à risque
d'être d'être compliqué hein tout le
monde tu es nul ne viendra qu'après les
will février ça risque d'être très
difficile on nous annonce déjà un mois
de mars terrible bon on voit bien et on
a une comment dirais-je une
communication du gouvernement qui est
très alarmiste qui vise à vraiment
tétanisé les français leur faire peur
pour leurs 10 pour les contraindre à
adopter vraiment des attitudes d'une
très grande prudence
est ce que la réalité sanitaire et celle
là on le verra aussi parce que les
français font beaucoup des fins ils font
beaucoup d'efforts
donc moi je trouve que dans la
communication du gouvernement il n'y a
jamais rien de positif qui reconnaissent
les efforts des français
et ça c'est un vrai problème cette
attitude là est ce qu elle peut mener à
une désobéissance civile voire à une
insurrection
je sais pas moi je trouve que les
français sont très résistants quand même
ça fait un an maintenant qu'ils sont
soumis à des contraintes absolument
terrible en matière de liberté
et ils sont résistants ils sont
courageux ils sont conscients qu'il faut
être prudent donc
je ne sens pas l'insurrection je sens
plutôt l'abattement le découragement
parce qu'il n'y a pas de perspective
parce que aussi tout se décide sans eux
c'est ce que je vous disais il faut
aussi qu'il puisse y avoir des débats un
moment alors voilà des débats dont les
termes soient adaptés à la situation que
nous vivons mais demander à l'état
d'urgence sanitaire plus court
c'est pas indigne non plus mais ça c'est
les 66 millions de procureur c'est la
même chose chez monsieur vers ans que
chez monsieur macron beaucoup dé lille
le courant parmi lesquels valérie
pécresse récemment dénonce le bazar de
la stratégie vaccinale à ce qu'il ya et
bien de la politique politicienne dans
leurs critiques
ah non c'est vraiment le bazar je vous
le confirme non quand on va les laisser
dans le dos à oui non mais quand valérie
pécresse parle de bazar elle a tout à
fait raison parce que c'est le bazar
pourquoi c'est le bazar parce que on a
dit finalement au maire vous allez
ouvrir les centres de vaccination les
maires ils sont extrêmement efficaces
donc en quelques heures en quelques
jours ils ont mis en place tout ce qu'il
fallait pour vacciner les français
et puis on leur dit
deux jours avant que ça ne commence bon
bah finalement ça sera pas exactement
organisé comme ça il y aura pas de
visites près vaccinale systématique bon
dont qui réorganise les centres de
vaccination et puis on leur dit il faut
à vous il faut toucher les publics
cibles les professionnels de santé les
plus de 75 ans ils le font on a toutes
les listes des des habitants tous les
maires ont sur leurs registres
évidemment contre analyses les plus de
75 ans ils les contactent mon les
contacts et ccs les personnels
municipaux ils sont contactés les rendez
vous sont pris et là on leur dit
maintenant il ya un problème parce que
vous allez devoir rappeler les gens pour
leur dire non vous avez pris un rendez
vous mais on pourra pas vous vacciner
parce qu'il ya pas de vaccin c'est le
bazar
effectivement et ça décrédibilise
complètement le gouvernement n'a pas
anticipé que les français y lirez
massivement la mecque dernière question
sur les vaccins car olivier véran cette
semaine devant les sénateurs a dit que
toutes les personnes fragiles ne
pourrait pas être vaccinées d'ici l'été
puis sur tf1 quelques heures plus tard
il a indiqué que 70 millions de
personnes seraient un hack signer fin
août
qu'est ce que vous en pensez est ce que
ça vous paraît que vous le croyez
écoutez je ne sais pas s'il faut croire
monsieur virant du matin où je vais
rendu soir parce que le même jour il
annonce je crois à 15 millions de
personnes et le soir c'est 70 70
millions bon 70 millions de doses parce
qu'il ya pas 70 millions de français moi
je ne sais pas s'il faut croire celui du
matin ou celui du soir
je crois que en matière de confiance il
faut une communication qui soit solide
et constante et là manifestement nous ne
l'avons pas et ça c'est un vrai sujet
comment les français peuvent-ils avoir
confiance dans une communication qui se
contredit qui est chaotique
c'est un sujet vraiment importants et
graves aller aux termites cette émission
avec l'adoption au sénat d'une
proposition de loi pour mieux lutter
contre les violences sexuelles sur les
mineurs
[Musique]
le texte crée un nouveau crime sexuel
pour protéger les mineurs de moins de 13
ans et dans le contexte de la sphère
duhamel s'est enrichi de mesures contre
l'inceste sandra cerqueira un vote à
l'unanimité au sénat
pour poser dans le droit un nouvel
interdit celui de tout rapport sexuel
avec un mineur de moins de 13 ans
concrètement en dessous de cet âge un
mineur serait donc automatiquement
considérés comme non consentants et
l'adulte poursuivi pour crime puni de
vingt ans de prison
si l'auteur connaissait ou ne pouvait
ignorer l'âge de la victime
les critères constitutifs du crime du
violent que sont la contrainte la menace
la violence ou la surprise reviennent à
faire porter l'appréciation du juge ou
du juré sur le comportement de la
victime et donc conduisent fatalement à
se poser la question de son consentement
avec ce texte on ne questionne plus le
comportement de l'enfant mais celui de
l'adulte
les tergiversations autour du
comportement de l'enfant ne pourront
plus des douanes et l'agresseur de sa
pleine et entière responsabilité pénale
d'emblée le garde des sceaux s'est
montré réservé et a appelé à ne pas
céder à la précipitation
nous souhaitons participer pleinement à
ces débats ce n'est pas les députés
contre les sénateurs les sénateurs
contre le gouvernement je sais rien on
est tous ensemble et unis dans une
véritable concertation mais je le redis
ya un certain nombre de divergences nous
aurons évidemment collectivement à
apporter une réponse dont je tiens ici à
préciser qu'elle doit être rapide les
sénateurs ont en revanche rejeté l'idée
de rendre imprescriptibles les crimes
sexuels sur mineurs à une exception si
l'auteur compte plusieurs victimes
la loi prévoit une suspension de la
prescription c'est souvent parce qu'il
est victime multiples que du coup
l'agresseur est confondu et que les
victimes sont crus et nous avons nous
l'avons vu dans la sphère flavie flament
et dans d'autres que les victimes
connaissent un sort qui leur semble ce
n'est pas faux inéquitable en raison de
la prescription
un amendement de la gauche a également
été votée visant à renforcer la sanction
encourue pour inceste sur mineure punie
de dix ans d'emprisonnement et 150 mille
euros damende cette proposition de loi
sera t-elle discuté à l'assemblée
nationale
si le gouvernement ne l'inscrit pas à
l'ordre du jour
le groupe socialiste s'est lui déjà dit
prêt à le faire créer un nouveau crime
sexuel puni de vingt ans de prison pour
protéger les mineurs de moins de 13 ans
on a entendu les arguments danic billon
trop souvent les critères du viol ne
parviennent pas être prouvée la question
du consentement ne doit pas se poser à
cet âge pour vous tout cela c'est une
bonne chose oui c'est une bonne chose je
crois véritablement qu'il faut punir
toute relation sexuelle d'un adulte d'un
majeur avec un enfant ça je pense que le
travail du sénat a été un très beau
travail
j'attends que l'assemblée nationale
inscrivent ce texte afin que nous
puissions d'examiner dans les meilleurs
délais le voiturier
oui bien sûr bien sûr il ya un seuil
d'âge de 13 ans qui a été retenue il ya
eu un débat sur wii reste marié l'âge de
la majorité sexuelle
si vous avez une religion si l'on peut
dire là dessus moi je serais tenté de
dire qu'un gens parce qu'ils me semble
que quinze ans maintenant
il ya tout de même à 15 ans une maturité
supérieure 13 ans est bien jeune mais
je pense que toutes ces questions
doivent être sérieusement évalué en tout
état de cause la révélation avec le
livre de camille kouchner c'est un peu
l'équivalent de 2000 tout est donc ça a
provoqué une vague de révélations qui
sont d'ailleurs terrifiante 1 et qui
appelle des réponses législatives très
très rapide
il faut en effet et j'ai beaucoup aimé
dans le reportage que vous avez passé
les propos de daniel guillon qui dit on
ne questionnera plus le comportement de
l'enfant mais on ira rechercher
uniquement la responsabilité de l'adulte
et puis l'aggravation en cas d'inceste
me semble tout à fait juste oui
justement effectivement le texte résonne
avec la sphère duhamel il a été enrichi
plutôt à la dernière minute de mesures
sur l'inceste un pour lui la grave et
oui voilà c'est une circonstance
aggravante l'inceste est ce que c'est
pour vous suffisant est ce que c'est le
bon timing est ce que c'est assez
réfléchi à ce qu'ils sont des
amendements de circonstance bas il y a
une actualité qui a joué le rôle
d'accélérateur de révélateur et sur des
faits aussi graves on peut pas rester
sans réaction
donc la rapidité ne veut pas dire que
les choses seront faites à la légère
ça veut dire que l'on va s'en saisir
rapidement mais le travail sera fait
sérieusement et solidement sur le plan
juridique
donc moi je pense qu'il n'ya pas c'est
pas une loi d'émotion qui qui dirait que
voilà on va réagir le plus vite possible
quitte à ne pas faire les choses que
cadres et calais juridiquement non je
crois que il ya des circonstances mais
il ya aussi urgence à légiférer pour que
pour que ces faits abominables soit à
leur juste mesure condamné un mot
rapidement sur la prescription la
proposition de loi augmente la
prescription s'il ya plusieurs victimes
identifiées on retiendra donc la
dernière victime connue est ce que pour
vous il fallait aller encore plus loin
il ya débat là dessus pour rendre en
fait c'est cela imprescriptible mois
dans un premier temps jeu il me semblait
que la prescriptibles it et était
quelque chose de justifiée dans la
mesure où la révélation des faits
quelquefois intervient très très
longtemps après la commission des faits
l'abonné yeux qu'un briquet et
quelquefois effectivement les victimes
sont
victime d'amnésie traumatique donc ça
justifierait la prescriptibles it et je
trouve que la disposition qui a été
introduite par là même de la gontrie
était studieuse dans ce sens que la
dernière victime lève la prescrivent il
a prescrit bilité de tous les deux les
autres donc ça c'est un sujet qu'il
faudra regarder au bon lorsque le texte
viendra en débat mais en tout cas la
question est ouverte
et l'ancien crima prescriptibles la
elle est légitime merci et à merci annie
genevard d'avoir insulté participer à
cette émission merci à vous tous de nous
avoir suivi on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro de
parlement hebdo
[Musique]